[Music]
20-19 has been an eventful year for
anime to say the least
real-world circumstances aside I'd say
the year has been a strong one as far as
exciting and thought inducing shows go
these shows help spice up the year in
addition to the plethora of sequels we
have for legacy shows like attack on
Titan my hero academia one punch man and
sword art online now on to the meat of
the video let's dive in to take a look
at the top non sequels of the year
[Music]
No
happiness of the many versus happiness
of a few what would you choose sounds
like something straight out of phase
zero but weathering with you the latest
sensation by Makoto Shinkai makes us
ponder the same question all over again
set in a not so distant future Tokyo
besieged with rain weathering with you
stars whole Dhaka a runaway looking to
find a bright future in the bustling
metropolis alas making a livelihood in
Tokyo's as tough as the rumors say along
the way he hears of the legendary
weather girl one who's rumored to have
the ability to stop the downpour across
Tokyo as fate would have it he's the
lucky guy who meets the urban legend
turns out that this girl holds the key
to Tokyo's salvation but at what cost
when the fated time comes
hidaka must make a painful choice will
he choose his happiness or the salvation
of the city blessed with Shinkai
signature narrative beads and some of
the best cinematography and art in 2019
weathering with use a proven winner you
shouldn't miss
[Music]
[Music]
for our next entry let's welcome some up
and comers ready to take the music world
by storm in Carolyn Tuesday set in Mars
Carolyn Tuesday puts two titular
characters with one another with
different backgrounds they come together
to pursue their passion of music now
that's easier said than done after all
they're up against the products of
technology as a eyes dominate the music
world
however it's unwise to underestimate the
human heart and will will the two of
them have what it takes to let their
sound resonate throughout the universe a
charming mix match between music drama
and sci-fi Karen Tuesday truly excels in
well building in my opinion the world's
intriguing and bright and warms everyone
up to the engaging characters looking to
make it big
I think the characterization starts off
promising but slows down towards the end
of the run but by that time you're so
immersed in the duo's journey it does
keep you watching till the end
Carolyn Tuesday's a nice story of human
creativity in connectivity
it's a budding story of expression and
at some points a truly inspiring one in
addition to being the year of sequels at
say 2019 s the year of remakes - for me
one of the better ones
Dora wrote deserves to make it to the
list Dora Rose the story of yukimaru a
ronin form without body parts due to an
ancient demon pact with each demon
defeated yaki maru regains a body part
and with Dora Roe and orphan he's met on
his journey
yukimaru continues his quest to regain
what's truly his among remakes Dora Rose
certainly had the most promising premise
and in my opinion it delivered on its
promise of an epic adventure of revenge
the series takes viewers through a dark
fantastical journey that blends the old
and modern times
I'd say the filler probably puts my
school for the show down a notch but I
didn't regret watching it if you're
planning to watch a remake as the year
ends
make sure to add d'Oro to your list
one of the biggest surprises in the last
season be stars proves to be a possible
sleeper hit don't let first impressions
fool you for most people be stars may
seem like outright furry bait or
pandering at first and in some ways I
agree as it does seem like that however
by this time we should be wise enough
not to let first impressions do all the
judging for us I dare say it's one of
the more underrated anime of the season
but that's only because it's
overshadowed by the billions of sequels
to popular series that ran alongside it
the art style and animation ought to
grow on you over time while the
interesting characters actually go
through a lot of nice development all
the way up nice parallels and social
commentary exist and you can really see
that B stars is a show that's crafted
with love and effort by the people
involved something to keep an eye out
for if you want a unique experience in
2019 who doesn't like a good ol space
adventure story of course what I'm
referring to is the story of Astra lost
in space as far as the community is
concerned starting without much traction
the series eventually endeared itself to
the hearts of millions of anime fans
with it's masterful developments and
plot twist after twist what seemed to at
first be a cheap anime knockoff of loss
turned out to be one of the most
underrated gems of the season honestly
speaking compared to its contemporaries
Astra lost in space doesn't provide any
adrenaline pumping scenes and segments
but more than makes up for in terms of
developing and fleshing out its
characters it may not be the space
orientated action series that some
people are looking for but Astra lost in
space is an example of space drama done
right
sci-fi lovers here's my pick for you in
2019
they got us they made us learn science
by watching anime doctor stowed one of
Shonen Jump biggest contributions this
year offers us some cool perspectives
given its realistic way of tackling the
main premise creation of a brand-new
world now you know what to do whenever
one of those people tells you you can't
learn anything good when watching anime
you see in a world where two boys are
pretty much the only survivors of a
catastrophic disaster they get assigned
a Herculean task breathing new life into
a world of stone beautiful visuals
excellent acting and an intriguing
premise with an air of mystery there's a
lot to like about dr. stone I personally
feel it's a shame that something this
good isn't shown in jumps biggest hit
this year then again being second to
arguably the biggest SJ phenomenon this
decades not a bad place to be in at all
[Music]
so so dafair Carrera is it any surprise
that this next entry wouldn't make it to
the best anime of 2019 list yep it's
about time we tackle Demon Slayer
make no mistake 2019 s demon slayers
year in the early parts of the year I
didn't expect this to blow up the way it
did
thanks to you foe tables amazing
production crew a cast of interesting
characters who have chemistry with one
another and a quick and simple narrative
style that's easy to follow Demon Slayer
has arguably become the biggest anime
sensation of 2019 I don't think you need
much of an introduction to this show
with the story about tangi Rose quest to
restore his sister's humanity making so
many waves all over the Internet watch
for the pretty visuals and music then
stay for the gripping narrative the
enjoyable characters and the exciting
battles that keep coming non-stop with a
movie and an inevitable second season
looming over the horizon things are only
going to get bigger and better for Demon
Slayer next up on the list is probably
my favorite comedy anime of the year
Kaguya summer as the subtitle goes love
is war and a very complicated one at
that need i say more
shootin Academy's two aces find each
other a formidable nemesis despite
developing feelings for each other
my Yuki and Kaguya find themselves in a
pickle after all
neither is willing to confess their
feelings to one another and according to
them the first one who does loses when
two of the biggest egos in the school
put their honour on the line one has to
wonder the lengths they'd go to in order
to win this battle of pride love is
indeed a battlefield and it's probably
the most precarious one of them all this
wacky story of love is refusing to
confess to each other's never been this
funny and entertaining in my opinion
Kaguya samus arguably one of the best
school comedy anime and it's not hard to
see why
[Music]
not topping the list but nevertheless
making a strong case for itself is the
promise Neverland count on one of the
more unorthodox shounen jump titles to
make it this high on the list forgoing
the usual superpowers in high-octane
action the promised Neverland instead
goes the route of Death Note and the
more methodical shows in the genre the
promised Neverland provides a complete
package fit for one that resolves around
the story of kids fighting for freedom
from the human farm known as grace
Fieldhouse the show's gripping tense and
suspenseful thanks to various animation
techniques and superb sound direction as
well as the abundance of twists the
anime grabs the viewer and sends them
into a thriller that's intense and
nerve-racking at every corner enjoying
its success off the heels of an
excellent run on top of a lot of
people's anime charts thanks to a
cathartic ending to the arc a second
season is on its way so make sure you
look out for it yes the much hyped and
awaited Vinland saga stands tall as the
number one non sequel in 2019 sure it
didn't blow up like Demon Slayer but
Vinland saga an amazing story of Vikings
in a boy's quest for revenge
more than deserves its crown of being
the best non sequel of 2019 instead of
being a violent revenge story you'd
expect from the premise Vinland sagas
more than that it's a graphic story
about the realities of war sprinkled
with historical angles that help you
appreciate the era which Studios
stunning animation and the world
building helped drop viewers into this
epic tale revenge and fantasy in
addition to the flashiness that is the
production villain saga also has great
substance with its character development
steadily paced from episode to episode
I'd say to crying shame the wild green
land saga had hype it was never the talk
of the town
seriously villain sagas criminally under
appreciated for what it brings to the
table it's the complete package and if
you picked up a show this year from what
I recommend This Is It this is what peak
anime in 2019 looks like now with the
year just about wrapping up these are my
recommendations for non sequels this
2019 that's it for now I'd love to see
you next time for more content like this
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and click the bell button so you're
first in line for new Vinny Tube content
[Music]